this presentation will review the
reagents solutions perkin elmer offers
for virology research
the global virology drug market is
expected to experience
tremendous growth in the next few years
the graph can be explained
by several factors combination therapies
used in hiv for example proven to be
beneficial
governmental institutions worldwide
provide guidelines to improve access to
anti-viral drugs
the mediatization of the latest virus
outbreaks like zika
ebola covet 19 as the industry paying
more and more attention to virology the
market is projected to reach 100 billion
by 2021.
this presentation is organized around
two sections in section one
we will have a look at the immune
response we will cover the topics of
vaccination
and have a look at the cells involved in
the development of the immune response
in particular the b cells and the t
cells
section 2 we will see what strategies
can be used to disrupt the virus life
cycle
we will highlight which of the
perkinalmer reagents
can be used there
okay so this first portion of the
presentation will cover the elaboration
of an immunization which is the purpose
of vaccination
first this is an overview of how an
antiviral immune response infers and
evolves from innate to adaptive immunity
to achieve immunization against the
virus the humeral response is the
proportion of immunity
that is responsible for the secretion of
soluble antibodies
and the storage of memory b cells that
provide
future immunity so that is through the
humeral response that immunization is
acquired
we split the evolution of the human
response in four stages
which will be addressed in later slides
so what happens
is when you have a virus entering the
body and infected cells
the infected cells will call for help
and the first ones to arrive
will be innate immunity cells nk cells
and dendritic cells
and that is the first step of the of the
figure
all those cells will co-stimulate each
other and move on to stage two
in stage two venetic cells will recruit
adaptive immunity cells
and prison them with antigenic bits of
virus
and infected cells they killed
in stage 3 the t cells will
differentiate into helper cells that
will promote stage 4
in which b cells will differentiate into
memory cells and antibody separating
cells and so stage four
is where you want to be after an
infection because it is the stage that
achieves
immunizations thanks to the memory cells
when you vaccinate
you play the animation nicole please
when you vaccinate you basically remove
the infected cells
and viral particles from the equation
and you replace them with your vaccine
which contains the armless antigen and
then the process is basically the same
so it is important to keep in mind that
vaccination and immunity are a matter of
inflammation
therefore cytokines inflammatory
pathways and inflammatory mediators
are the hallmarks of those processes
specifically when monitoring
inflammation
a set of inflammatory mediators are very
important because they bind receptors
and activate stimulatory pathways in all
immune cells
these are shown on the slide ielsis tnf
alpha and the elephants
as well as some pathways and cytokines
expression they promote and you have the
jack start pathways
nf fk pathways mapkins pathway
especially
on the next slide in relation to those
ubiquitous inflammatory pathways
one reason why cytokines cytokine
panelists are relevant in the current
situation
is explained here in several cases
some publications have started to
discuss the cyclohindstorm effect in
covenanting infection
and basically what it means is that in
an attempt to defend itself
from the virus the body overexpresses
multiple cytokines in a short time
due to pro-inflammatory signal loops and
the other inflammation ends up being
more harmful than helpful
some researchers have already started to
investigate ways to monitor
and mitigate this cytokine storm by
pulling string
strings up streams in some cytokines
levels and pathways
such as the ones we saw before ilc tnf
alpha and the jackson pathways
while we are still talking of
pro-inflammatory mediators in the
kovin-19
c-reactive protein was found by several
papers to rise through the progression
of the disease
and to be a part of the cytokine storm
so the reactive protein is an
inflammatory marker produced by the
liver
and which can be typical of viral
infections because it is a co-activator
of the complement
which is shown on the slide and briefly
what the complement does
is enhance the anterior power of
antibodies by allowing easier targeting
of infected cells and viral particles
through optimization of those
so this first slide of this first type
of slide
uh basically shows the solution that
perkin armor offers
to tackle all the cytokine and
inflammatory mediators
field of research
we are now going to talk about the
antiviral immune response in itself
when there is a viral infection the very
first reaction
is that of the infected cells which is
the highlighted part of the figure
very often in the body cells close from
an interface with the environment
so epithelial cells they feature
additional
inflammatory strategies compared to
regular cells
the inflammasome and seagusting
axis pathways shown on the slide are
such strategies
in the case of the inflammasome it
allows the detection
of cytosolic foreign patterns including
double stranded rna
other nucleic acids peptides from
bacterial walls or viral capsids
and the inflammatory activation ends up
releasing pro-inflammatory mediators
such as
il-1 beta il-18 and atm gb1
in the case of c-gasting access as you
may know it is a powerful tool to detect
cytosolic double-stranded dna
which is not supposed to be present in
the cytosol
when it does it triggers the release of
pro-inflammatory mediators as well
and those are a little bit different
because they involve inf alpha and beta
as well as tnf alpha and ilces
so this is it for the antiviral reaction
of infected cells
and we will now be moving to the innate
immunity cells response
vaccines are made of a variety of
ingredients including antigens
stabilizers adjuvants and preservatives
the antigen is the main active
ingredient of the vaccine
it is used to generate the protective
immune response
events play an essential role in the
induction of immunity
adjuvants are increasingly being
perceived as essential to the vaccine
success
search around discovering new adjuvants
is very active
many adjuvants used in modern vaccines
are toll-like receptors agonists
we will see two examples of fda approve
adjuvants
in this presentation
throughout the presentation we want to
make sure you can quickly visualize
where in the immune cascade the perk
number reagents fit
anthritic cells and natural killers are
the first cells to encounter pathogens
during the process of vaccination they
are also the first cells to respond to
the antigen
and the adjuvant in the
here are two fda approved adjuvants to
introduce the concept
as01b is made of an immune boosting
substance
isolated from the surface of bacteria
which begs the question why would a
bacterial lipid
be used in the composition of a vaccine
against the virus
the answer to that question resides in
the toll-like receptor pathway
we will see in the next slide cpg 1018
it is also approved by the fda for vax
for using vaccines
cpg 1018 is not a lipid but rather it is
a synthetic oligodeoxynucleotide nutella
type
made of cpg motifs
so how do cpg 1018 and asb-01
work the answer is they activate the
toll-like receptors
like receptors are a class of proteins
that play a key role in the innate
immunity system
elrs represented in yellow on the slide
are usually expressed on sentinel cells
such as
phages and the dendritic cells recognize
structurally
conserved molecules derived from
bacteria
activation of tlr by adjuvants enhances
the dendritic cell function and their
ability to prime t
cells which in turn makes them more
prone to develop an immune response
also note that aging is accompanied by a
progressive decline in both innate and
acquired immune system
referred to as immunosenescence
therefore there is still a great need
for vaccines that are tailored to
optimally stimulate the aged immune
system
this light summarizes all the products
perkinelmer has
available for toll-like receptor
okay um we will now be looking at the
solutions for monitoring our next
highlighted step on the figure which
corresponds to
t cells and b cells activation following
antigen presentation
so this first slide shows you the
activation pathway of t
cells as well as the interaction with
other immune cells it requires
we will not be describing this pathway
in detail
just be aware that it exists and it is a
mandatory step on the way to
immunization and therefore
there is an interest in monitoring it
when investigating vaccine candidates
this slide is the
next yeah this slide is the same as the
previous one
but applied to b cell activation so once
again you have
the activation pathway the relationship
to other immune cells
and once again it is a necessary step to
immunization
and an interesting one to study for
vaccine candidates
so once again couple summary slides that
list the solutions
uh that prequel number offers to match
the processes which is so
this one refers to the inflammasome csx
axis
and other key inflammatory pathways as
well as the major inflammatory cytokines
involved in immunity
and the next one gathers the product
related to t cell and the cell
activation pathways
okay in this next part we will be
looking at
the next portion of the figure which
corresponds to
the activity of differentiated t cells
and b cell
so in your back sign development process
you are the point where
you want to monitor the immune response
and make sure that it happened
as you expected it to so the next slide
is going to be about
monitoring the activity of
differentiated t
cells differentiated t cells exist in
two main families
first up we have the the el the helper t
cells
which fulfill a role of supports for the
other immune cells
they exist in different types which are
characterized by the cytokine
cocktail that trigger them the cytokines
they express
and the type of support they provide all
of which are featured in the table on
the slide
they are all relevant to study in
overall immune responses
but the helper t cells type 2 are
especially relevant to the immunization
process of vaccination
because their direct contribution is
required for b
cells to evolve into antibody circuiting
cells and memory cells
the main molecules of interest for
monitoring those cells activity are the
cytokines and transcription factors they
respectively express
and that are featured on the table
next we have the other family of t cells
which are the cytotoxic ones these are
in charge of removing infected cells
by forcing them into apoptosis therefore
their activity
is characterized by their cytotoxic
behavior
they have three main ways of inducing
death into a target
which they most often combine they can
use the ethyl again
they carry on their surface and which
trigger the caspase apoptotic pathway
inside the target cell they can inject
the infected cells with perforins
and granzymes which also trigger the
casper by sway
and finally they can release high
amounts of tnf alpha which binds tnfr-1
and promotes cell death as well in terms
of monitoring their activity we are
interested
in the granzyin perforin axis the tnfr
fast suppression slash tnf
binding and of course anything that
provides a reading of hypothesis
so once again this is the slide that
gathers the different products available
for
each cell type activity we've seen
the following slides were designed based
off the work of andrew bett
at merck work that was published in
nature in 2020
a show america used out of eliza to
select antigens having the best
chance of leading to the development of
neutralizing antibodies
as the rsv virus rsv causes respiratory
tract illness worldwide with substantial
morbidity in infants
and despite the clear medical need a
licensed rsv vaccine
is not yet available to understand our
merck is using alpha liza
to produce a vaccine we must look at the
virus itself
the virus main protein is called the f
protein
during the viral vaccine in vaccination
infection
the f protein exists in two forms the
prefusion and the post-fusion protein
both are attractive antigens for vaccine
preparation
to build a vaccine against rsv merck
uses a technology called
lipid nanoparticles encapsulated
messenger
although the name may appear daunting
the principle is quite simple
nucleic acid-based vaccines consist of a
messenger rna
coding for the viral protein
encapsulated within lipids
mice treated with the vaccine transcribe
the messenger rna
into the viral protein and as a result
start developing a strong immune
response
against it merck uses alpha elisa to
quantify the immune response
and in doing so to select the best
messenger rna candidates
for the vaccine development
so how does it work exactly merck starts
with preparing several messenger rna
candidates
each encoding various forms of the rsvf
protein
the vaccines are then given to mice and
rats
aram of the mice and rats are then
collected and assessed for the presence
of neutralizing antibodies
against the rsv protein this is where
alfaliza becomes extremely useful
using alpha lysa merck built a
competitive binding immunoassay
made of the f protein conjugated to
acceptor beads
along with a non-neutralizing antibody
coated onto donor beads
it is essential at this stage to
understand that merck is using as a
reference
antibodies that are known to be
neutralizing bali visualab for example
is licensed by the ada for use in
preventing
severe lower respiratory tract
infections
caused by rsv
the diagram in the top shows o shows a
messenger rna vaccine
that does not lead to a useful response
the serum of the mice when tested in the
alpha lizard assay
do not lead to a competition which
indicates that they do not have any
or enough neutralizing antibodies
diagram at the bottom shows a messenger
rna vaccine
does lead to a useful response the
theorem of the mice
when tested in the alkalizer assay lead
to a competition
which indicates that they do contain a
substantial amount of neutralizing
antibodies
the following slides describe part of
the work of a 2019 published study
on recess protection against hiv using
an antigenic hiv capsid primer that
promotes
nano antibodies aggression and the point
of interest with this
publication is that they used a
luminescence assay
to assess the efficacy of that
antibodies
they used 78 monkeys which they
inoculated with the capsid primer
then they tighter the nano antibodies of
all monkeys and split them into
high and low nano antibody title groups
they also
kept a non-vaccinated control group
moving on to the essay what the authors
wanted was
to know whether the nano antibodies
would be good at promoting the death of
infected cells through adcc
to do so they incubated cells expressing
luciferase upon infection with simian
hiv particles
to create an infected population of
cells then
they added nk cells to the mix as well
as serum from all produced legendary
terrestris groups
finally after an incubation time they
added
the bright light luciferase substrate
and on the next slide what happens when
they add the substrate goes
like this
on the next slide please nicole
if you have effective nano antibodies
capable of triggering a dcc which stands
for
antibody driven cells toxicity then you
are going to have a low luciferase
luminescence
because the nano antibodies will drive
the nk cells to kill the infected cells
which causes a loss of luciferase and
this is the scenario shown on the right
panel of this slide
but if you do not have effectiveness
antibodies or not enough of them
the adccc will be weak and fewer
infected cells will be killed
hence the luciferase luminescence will
be higher this this is the left
left panel of that slide
uh as usual you can find the perkinalmer
luminescence solution for
conducting that kind of asset we
described on the slide
we're now moving into the detection of
the immune response
detecting the production of antibodies
especially igm
which are produced rapidly after the
infection is a classic strategy to
profile the early humoral response
detection of igg iga and igm can easily
be achieved
using elisa's and htrf or alpha lysa
based assays
early moon a parking armor company
developed two elisa for the detection of
anti-covet 19
iga and igg in serum the purpose of
these two elisa's is diagnostic
the objective is to test patient samples
for the presence of anti-covet 19
antibodies which in turn
would indicate that the patients have
been infected
not however that similar elisa formats
can be used for serous surveillance as
well as screening for the best vaccine
candidates
this 2020 paper was published by the
veterinary and animal medicine team at
iowa state university
and clearly shows how alpha liza can be
used to detect an immune response
porcelain diarrhea is caused by the ped
virus
the absence of effective vaccines
infection prevention
and control through diagnostic testing
and quarantine are critical
the study highlights the use of alpha
liza for the purpose of making that
diagnostic
in pigs the figure is taken straight out
of the paper
and it shows the development of two
alpha lysa assays
the first assay uses a recombinant viral
protein conjugated to both donor and
acceptor alphabets
this is a classic alpha liza bridging
assay
designed to quantify the total immune
response
igm iggs and igas will be bridge
will breach the donor and acceptor beads
resulting in a quantifiable signal
in the second assay the viral protein is
conjugated to an alpha lysa acceptor
beat
biotinylated anti-pig-iga or
biotinylated anti-piga-gg
are added to the samples to detect a igg
or ige-specific response what are the
graphs showing
they show detectable iga and igg
response in infected peaks
the conclusion is the following
alphaliza is an immunoassay platform
that can be used to detect early immune
response
in serum
this slide summarizes all of the alpha
and hdrf products that can be used
to conduct research all the ig classes
are represented
and this slide is a map that positions
all the
solutions we've just reviewed so far on
the immunity and immunization process
that we've described
custom labeling should all can be
positive can be used
when when doing virology research
breaking number has over 20 years of
experience in labeling any type of
material with a large diversity of dyes
using all the main labeling techniques
okay this closes the first part of the
presentation
on the vaccination process and the
immune response
we are now moving on to the second part
of this presentation which will
address the viral life cycle and how
therapeutic research
attempts to monitor and disrupt it
so first of all this slide represents
the
six distinct steps that make up the
virus life cycle
the steps are pretty self-explanatory
understood on the figure
first a viruses needs to attach
themselves to their host cell
this is the attachment step and it is
done using viral capsid proteins that
mimic the ligand of some
of the host cell receptors the second
step
consists in shedding the capsid to free
the viral proteins
and the genetic material it this is the
encoding step
thirdly you have the integration
in in which the virus genetic material
is integrated
inside the host genome the fourth step
is the replication
which basically means that the virus is
hijacking the
cell synthesis processes and mechanism
to replicate itself in fifth you have
the newly formed components
assembling into new viral particles this
is the assembly step
and the final and sixth step is the
release of newly formed viral particle
outside of the the host cell
which most often causes the death of
that host cell
and then the cycle goes on so the first
part
of the presentation is going to be
dedicated to
ppi as a format that has been used by
researchers to attempt to find
inhibitors of
any of that virus cycle
uh like virus viral cycle so
in the first in this first example in
this publication from guyalid
gilead the research team was targeting
the integration
step of hiv what no
sorry
the first this first slide is an example
for a medium
and it is an example of the kind of ppa
assets that can be designed to study the
attachment step
of the virus cycle the virus
investigated here
is hrv and it is known to bind the ecom1
proteins of its host surface
here the team from medellin was looking
to isolate a high affinity
fully human monoclonal antibody to ecom1
that would be capable of inhibiting the
binding of hrv
the essay they built is described on the
slide and based on three partners
first you have a recombinant human ecom1
fc camera
labeled with european cryptate second
you have
a soluble human echemon flag and third
an acceptor labeled anti-flag antibody
also note that this assay issue is using
live hrv and not some approximative
model of the virus so as you can see on
the slide
if you mix all the partners with the
virus the
ecom1 proteins are going to bind the
virus
and trigger threats and then the
introduction of inhibitors is going to
prevent ecam1
binding and shut down the threat signal
on the next slide is
uh illustrated from a publication from
gilead
the research team was targeting the
integration
step of hiv to integrate itself
this virus takes advantage of one of its
host growth factor
the led gf this factor naturally binds
the dna to fulfill its role
and so the hiv virus uses this bone to
find its way to its host dna
on the virus side the binding partner is
a dimer of retroviral integrase
that interacts with the led gf
so here the team was looking to identify
inhibitors of the integrase ld led gf
interaction and to do that
they built the two ss presented on the
slide
the first one was an integrase led
led gf interaction essay and its goal
was to
identify the thought after inhibitors
and the second essay was
an integrase dimerization essay and its
goal was to
make sure that the inhibitors found with
the first assay
would not be inhibitors of the
integrated memorization
only but inhibitors of the interaction
between between led gf
and integrase
i will not spend time on this next slide
it is just a collection of publications
that
have used the specific ppisa formats to
investigate
hiv integration step for about 10 years
and this final slide refers to
a publication that attempted to identify
inhibitors
of viral assembly of the hepatitis c
virus
the assembly step is basically the
capsid proteins being put together
around the virus genetic material and in
the case of hcv
the capsid is critically dependent on
one varicon
protein named core which undergoes
dimerization to build the capsid
in this publication the researchers used
n-terminal 106 residue
portions of that core proteins labeled
core 106 on the slide
and they tagged them with gst and flag
respectively
then using anti-tag antibodies labeled
with htrf reagents
they built the essay you see on the
slide to identify inhibitors of cold
memorization
and this as saying the publication was
used to screen two libraries
of about thirteen hundred and twenty
three hundred compounds respectively
and was successful at identifying a few
potential inhibitors
this slide as usual um is a short list
of
the solutions that can be proposed by
perkiner
for that type of ppi study
we are now moving on to the cytotic
cytotoxicity and cellular
cellular death part of the presentation
ultimately during viral infection
some infected cells die and there is an
interest in monitoring that event when
researching antiviral drugs
there are different reasons for cell
death and the main ones
are one infected cells kill themselves
through hypothesis
two viral particles became so elevated
in the cell
that they trigger its death and three
some immune cells
as we saw are capable of inducing
hypothesis inside infected
cells whichever the reason hallmarks of
cellular death are the caspase pathway
and dna fragmentation
this is a quick look at phosphoh2ax
which is one of those dna fragmentation
marker
it is a histam and its phosphor
phosphorylated state is a
specific marker of double stranded dna
breaks
more specifically this this molecule is
responsible for
putting the cell cycle on pose to give
time to the cells to reaper its dna and
that's why it is a very relevant
molecule to monitor when looking for
cytotoxic
psychotoxicity markers
moving on to viability assays
the luminescence firefly luciferase
based
atp light assays are also an alternative
to colorimetric fluometric
and radioisotopic assets to monitor
cell proliferation and overall viability
and they work by monitoring the atp
levels which
are an indicator of cells health since
atp is a molecule
involved at every level of cell cells
metabolism
once again this slide is the usual
summary of the solutions
that have just been mentioned for this
specific step
the hdrf double-stranded rnase
specifically measures double-stranded
rna
a special form of rna produced in the
process
of virus replication in other words
presence of double
trended rna in cells should be
considered downstream evidence
of the viral infection importantly
even if the virus genome does not
consist of double stranded
any types of viruses can generate
double-stranded rna
as an intermediate product when
replicating as a consequence the kit can
be offered
for all classes of viruses
double-stranded rna
and non-double-stranded rna
if you're a researcher and you're
looking for a wealth of validation data
on the kit
i direct you to the paper published by
curing in 2019
which reference is on this
while the double-stranded rna kit allows
the detection
to detect the presence of
double-stranded rna in cells
as a proxy for viral replication other
kits
have been developed to look at viral
proliferation
in the alphalisa format several kits are
available
for the detection of specific viral
proteins
light features the alpha lysa kit for
hepatitis b virus surface antigen
protein that can be detected in high
levels in serum
during acute and chronic hepatitis b
infection
it's built on the same format are also
available to detect hiv p24
influenza nucleoprotein hepatitis c core
antigen
and hepatitis b core antigen
number website has more information
about each of the kids
and finally the plaque assay is the
standard method
used to determine virus concentration
the method consists in determining the
number of plaques forming when samples
are inoculated
with a viral solution in many
laboratories
counting the plaques is performed
manually either by visual inspection or
using a microscope
turkey elmer has developed an
application note that shows how the
plaque imaging
and analysis can be automated using the
inside
reader on this slide are all the
products
that can be used to study the viral
infection step
sarilumab a human monoclonal antibody
against the interleukin-6 receptor
return around pharmaceutical and sanofi
developed the drug for the treatment of
rheumatoid arthritis
for which it received u.s fda
approval in 2017. cerelumab works by
reducing the effect
of a substance in the body that can
cause inflammation namely il-6
now you may ask what does a drug
approved for autoimmunity
has to do with virology and the answer
is inflammation
il-6 may play a role in driving the
overactive inflammatory response in the
lugs of patients
that are severely afflicted with covid19
blocking ir6 signaling may be very
beneficial for these patients
patients that suffer not only from
autoimmune diseases as well as those
patients that were infected
by the covin-19 virus
unwanted immunogenicity is an immune
response by an organism against an
antibody drug
this reaction leads to the production of
ads anti-drug antibodies
inactivating the therapeutic effects of
the treatment and in some rare
cases also inducing adverse effects
for the sake of time i will leave it at
this bridging assays
which are represented on the slides are
often used to detect the ada response
this can be developed using the htrf or
alpha toolbox
format to build a bridging assay the
antibody drug
must be labeled with both the acceptor
and donor floor of wars
or the acceptor and donor beads the
labeling can be
done in-house directly or through the
prokane number custom labeling services
okay so same as the solution map we saw
in the vaccinations section
this slide reviews the viral life cycle
and points
the different solutions that
prerequisite offers
to in terms of reagents to address every
each step of the cycle
and finally the perky number websites as
many resources
posters application notes and heights
that can help you visualize where the
reagents can be used for research or ppi
research